I love this this slide deck and I have
from the very start should come to our
industry standard conferences in the
bubble and share it with us now she's
sharing it in front of a different
conference crowd today but it's some of
the things they're talking about here
are really shocking not least of which
is slowing growth rates in the Internet
dramatically slowing growth rates in the
Internet that's right Corey one of the
reasons for that that she points to and
one of the reasons people love this
report so much is that she gets up out
of the everyday and she goes back 20 30
40 50 years and one of the things she
points to is that China has just been on
this massive building boom there's been
21 trillion dollars of capital growth
during the past six years invested
compared to and that's more than was
done in the previous 30 so there's been
this massive run-up in China that's now
starting to taper off and as a result
the numbers overall are coming down to
business has developed markets are
developed exactly except for India that
was the 11 stand talking about that what
did she say what India there's still
room for growth they are still growing
it was the one country that did see some
positive uptick in internet usage of new
users and also smartphone users and now
it is the second-largest market just
behind China passing the United States
now John a big part of that of course is
mobile consumption and the notions from
the support about what's happening with
smartphones and what's happened to
mobile you know most these users will
never see a desktop particularly uses
that are yet to be added I mean they are
adding numbers but without China it
would be pretty much flat the growth
rate would at least it makes it with us
are without India to be flat but again
this is all happening on smartphones
yeah I mean one thing to keep in mind on
it India is the fact that Indians love
their cheap phones so if you look at the
average smartphone price in india it's
down around 120 dollars it's up around
280 in china so in terms of the revenue
opportunity for big vendors like Apple
and Samsung China was a much richer
market and you know you were referring
before about the slowdown in China let's
put it into context five and a half
years ago in 2010 that was a market
growing well over a hundred
sent this year the unit growth in China
is our I'm sorry in 2015 the unit growth
in China was about one and a half
percent so we've seen a very rapid slow
down there due to saturation all eyes
now have shifted to India where the unit
growth opportunity is high but the
revenue opportunity I think is going to
be lower just because we're talking
about the popularity of those lower
priced well right but that was a
prediction of China when that market had
yet to take off a few years ago and an
apple in particular bolide that they
came with most expensive phone they've
ever had and was a huge success in China
yeah I think that's fair i mean one
thing that we're looking for in india is
they really don't have a lot of 4g
networks there and so as those 4g LTE
networks that we love so much here in
the US begin to get built out nationwide
in india they're going to need 4g phones
to access and really leverage the power
of those networks and that means paying
for a higher priced phone